[Music]
King caught most of
Silvia with crown princes
[Music]
have arrived
as well as contacted captain
[Music]
[Applause]
and now we will hear March in the major
Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart which is the
music that is played when the laureates
enter the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody rises for the laureates first
in line is a true harmoo whole physics
period followed by his physics colleague
laureate Donna Strickland Francis Arnold
one of these years
chemistry laureates where the truth
Smith and sir Gregory winter I her side
to the right also chemistry laureates
and then we have changed Alison and
tatsuko Hanoi this year's medicine
laureates and to the far right there we
have William Nordhaus and Paul Romer
economics
[Music]
all in all 12 laureates this year
including the Peace Laureates Denis
Micawber and Nadia Murad who earlier
today received the Peace Prize in Oslo
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
esteemed Nobel laureates
ladies and gentlemen call Henry
Killinger foundation it's a great
pleasure for me to welcome you all to
this year's Nobel Prize award ceremony
in particular I would like to welcome
the Nobel laureates and their families
to this ceremony earlier today in Oslo
they need Beckley again and madhyama rod
were awarded a Nobel Peace Prize for
their efforts to end the use of sexual
violence as a weapon of war and armed
conflict through this price when a
region of L committee reminds us that
human rights must include also rights of
women too often women have been violated
in conflicts as a way of disrupting a
society words cannot describe the
horrors that madam rod has lived through
but we should be grateful that she has
decided to share her story with us as a
call for action dr. Denis McKeon has
likewise shown exceptional courage and
persistence when he at great personal
risk has alleviated the suffering of so
many women in the Congo Alfred Nobel's
vision was to reward those who have made
the greatest benefit to humankind
in science literature and peace and
thereby have contributed to a better
world undoubtedly the world has in many
ways become a better place since the end
of the 19th century when Alfred Nobel
lived however in recent years we have
unfortunate
clean new dangerous tendencies on the
rise while the Paris agreement is a sign
that a question of global warming is
taking seriously it is deeply worrying
that influential world leaders are
denying the connection despite of
overwhelming scientific evidence between
our lifestyle and climate change and
preventing the necessary actions from
being taken also in other fields we see
that facts observations and information
are distorted or in the world we see how
nationalism and isolationism are
increasing with restrictions in trade
cultural exchange and movement across
borders together dissing dangers the
world as we know it science offer a
counter movement to the isolation istic
and fact resistant tendencies we see it
has no borders and scientists often move
between countries science is our times
lingua franca and can form bridges
between countries and cultures the
importance of research is therefore not
only limited to the generation of new
knowledge but it serves a more general
role providing a common ground for
interactions between people all over the
world
moreover modern science does not only
involve skeptical inquiry but is also
often led by Jesus of openness and
tolerance today we do not only celebrate
a Nobel Prize
it is also 70 years ago that the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
was adopted by the United Nations and 50
years since Renee Kazan received a Nobel
Prize for his work with the declaration
this serves to remind us that one of the
reasons that modern society has
progressed is that it has created a set
of institutions and instrum
that formalizes progress Human Rights is
one of these as is science and democracy
but again we cannot take these
institutions and instruments for granted
we are all aware of the increasing
questioning of universal human rights
freedom of speech an academic
independence all values closely
connected with what a nobel prize stands
for this is deeply troubling since we
risk a regression to a time before they
existed to a time ruled by ignorance
prejudice and barbarism do now more than
900 Nobel laureates and that
achievements are a source of inspiration
to us all
the well visited museums in Stockholm
and Oslo various events in different
countries and through our digital
channels with millions of followers we
are reaching out all over the globe to
tell their stories to further enhance
our outreach activities we have been
working hard with support from the alien
passion Family Foundation and ignite an
ALICE valid Alice Valentine Foundation
and many other donors to achieve a noble
Centre in the heart of Stockholm we
would like to take this opportunity to
thank them as well as the architects
David Chipperfield and Kristoff Felger
for their support and commitment despite
the setback we now had with the
decisions taking by the new ruling
majority in Stockholm we are prepared to
continue to work for this idea it is
simply too good to be stopped however
given what has happened we have to be
clear if Stockholm is going to get a
Nobel Center strong concrete and
reliable support from the city of
Stockholm as well as from the government
of Sweden will be needed scientific
breakthroughs of the kind we honor today
are all fostered by creating strong
environments and by giving excellent
scientists freedom independence and long
term funding such creative milliards
become fertile for new ideas through
being open to a diversity of skills
experiences and cultural backgrounds and
through letting young scientists speak
their mind in strong scientific
environments the focus is often on basic
research that is curiosity driven
research which does not aim at solving a
practical problem but only aims at
answering interesting and important
questions Max Planck the 1918 Nobel
laureate in physics went so far as to
say scientific discovery and scientific
knowledge have been achieved only by
those who have gone in pursuit of it
without any practical purpose whatsoever
in view remarkably however many basic
research discoveries have later on been
proven to have practical usefulness
often in unexpected areas in this way
advances in basic science becomes part
of the progress that Alfred Nobel wished
to see the production of new knowledge
just does joins the struggle for human
rights in these awards which we hope can
inspire in particular young people to
make even more remarkable contributions
for the benefit of humankind
thank you for listening and once again
most welcome to this year's Nobel Prize
award ceremony
we have been chairman of the board of
the Nobel foundation before the first
prizes are to be handed over by His
Majesty the King and the first laureate
to receive it will be Shama but first
some music by Claude Debussy
French composer
[Music]
[Applause]
and sunlight is essential to live on
earth harnessing its energy in many
other ways today to avenge author asking
builders Ashkan is optical tweezers
orders have their application to
biological system then this invention is
based on the ability of light to exert a
force on the matter the main tone as
radiation is pressure
Marie Hilton the possibility of using
light via this force fluid move of
physical objects may make one thing Star
Trek and tractor beams and sound like
pure science fiction science fiction
Milligan close we can feel that Sun
beams carry energy make us warm maybe
but we cannot feel any small push trough
them for induce the force of this Sun
light is too weak to do so the starting
point that led hashed into this optical
tweezer was an experiment showing that
radiation laser light could not only
move such particles but could also be
made to grab them by focusing the beam
with the help of the Lance rollin focus
a $1 million Ivan Lin's then will mark
the birth of the optical tweezers gained
range of applications and that lets us
hold onto and move objects such as Linux
without metal wooden home flash guns
method has been successfully used to
investigate various components of
biological cells among other thing was
providing us with knowledge about the
mechanics of tiny molecular motors and
perform vital work inside these cells
strickland below being rewarded for an
invention called chirped pulse
amplification extremely trickling
efforts to create intense laser process
way since the first place was built in
1966 these experiments at regional
impasse since the intensity of the laser
line destroyed the material itself
reducing it to film numerous
applications of laser pulses are being
made possible one example is correcting
which lasers ultra surgical dr. Raskin
professor professor Strickland you have
been awarded the 2018 Nobel Prize in
Physics for your groundbreaking
inventions in the field of laser physics
on behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy
of Sciences it's my honor and great
pleasure to convey to you our warmest
congratulations
relations I now ask you to step forward
to receive your Nobel Prizes from the
hands of His Majesty the King
I welcome professor Michael asking to
receive the prize on behalf of his
father author asking that was the
presentation speech by Professor Andrew
Beck member of the Royal Swedish Academy
of Sciences one wonder was what what the
King might be saying now perhaps say
hello to your father he's probably
watching this
Michael African son of Arthur
Ashkan receiving this physics prize
Michael Ashkan himself a professor of
Arts
[Applause]
Schama born in France also receives his
parts
[Music]
[Applause]
and Donna Theo Strickland born in 1959
in Ontario Canada receives her part 2018
about physics
there's some music by Charles T grifs
we will hear soloist Christina Nelson
and stuck on the Royal Stockholm
Philharmonic Orchestra
the piece is the lament of Ian the proud
from the three poems of Fiona MacLeod
[Music]
[Applause]
but after zoom interviewed the price
award seminar will continue with a
presentation of the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry speech by Professor Soros Nora
linson who is a member of the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences and member
of the Nobel Committee for chemistry it
is nice that Majesties your Royal
Highnesses esteemed not a laureate the
many who we humans believe we know
everything
many of land sometimes it may be more
fruitful to acknowledge our incompetence
believe them entrust the superior
performance of Mother Nature an element
of chance can work wonders in the lab
the level of success may be higher if
one allows oneself the luxury of years
adapted refined the chemistry of life
all this allows various organisms to
coexist in a thriving all sorts of
possible and seemingly impossible in
nature evolution has changes that
adapted to its environment increased the
chances for survival and new employment
can be added over generations of Steel
II cor man Deanna Horner Francis Arnold
had a define plan where she set up
directed evolution in her laboratory she
wanted to make a greener chemical
industry and produce biofuels in a
sustainable way
Emilio validus it Frances Arnold
harnessed the power of evolution and
made it a versatile tool for improving
nature's own catalyst
Symes coonley she also made it possible
to create new biocatalysts that can
speed up reactions not seen nature some
in the horn organ mode so hit in at one
time off the time through smart
combinations of knowledge and chance she
created em science and math for the
greatest benefit of the humankind not oh
that's 14 proteins in nature can also
make wonders by interacting and
intriguing your George Smith developed a
method to create very large collections
of similar proteins and then using a
molecular baked we can fish out the
members of their collection that were
most strongly attracted to the bait he
constructed his method so that every
protein carries with it the recipe for
its own production lacking this feature
makes it easy to make new copies of the
best proteins that engage them in a
tighter competition for the bait in need
make it too far out having Oh Mia jokin
Gregory Gregory winters sharpen the
fishing tours for the development of
pharmaceuticals and antibodies are large
and complex molecules
[Music]
antek oppa is still a complex app for
Dana McGregor a winter vault the winter
chose to work with a small fragment that
carries all the variations seen among
natural antibodies as a result became a
powerful method for deriving new
antibodies diagnostics and treatments
for having antibodies with high
precision can it hurt strongly and
persistently to other molecules or cell
surfaces to facilitate or interfere with
their duties Frances Arnold Gregory
Smith George Smith sorry in Gregory
winter your work has led to the
development of enzymes for a greener
chemistry and antibodies that save lives
that's a truly great achievement on
behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences I wish to convey to you our
warmest congratulations mayor now asked
you to step forward and receive your
Nobel prizes from the hands of His
Majesty the King first jersey the price
is Frances Arnold of the California
Institute of Technology in Pasadena
United States who receives one half of
this year's chemistry prize for the
directed evolution of enzymes
[Music]
and the other half is jointly awarded to
George Smith of University of misery
misery in the United States
[Music]
who receives it's jointly
with Gregory winter of the MRC
Laboratory of Molecular Biology at
Cambridge UK for the phage display of
peptides and antibodies
[Music]
enjoy some more music the alligretto
armada volley from the symphony in C
minor by composer Alice Mary Smith
[Music]
chemistry laureate Francis Arnold
her cancer was actually one of she was
one of the first to have it cured by his
Pfeiffer laureate colleague Gregory
winters method and this year's medicine
prize is definitely about cancer therapy
now we will hear the presentations my
close you know on the road on cancer
cancer one of the greatest eCourse
quarters of humanity is caused by the
uncontrolled proliferation of deceased
cells that can spread in the body and
for metastasis the cancer therapy has
been based on three pillars of surgery
radiotherapy and drugs that attack
cancer cells today more than two-thirds
of cancers are cured but the deceased
still claims millions of lives every
year there's a great need for new forms
of therapy and for a long time
researchers have pinned their hopes on
the possibility of utilizing our immune
system normally protects us against
infections immune system is based on a
diversified array of instruments in the
form of various cells and molecules each
of them has its own special sound and
technical requirements to get them to
work a bit like the instruments mistre
here today the new system is to
distinguish between foreign cells and
Americans and the body's own cells which
must if we add T cells it was a kind of
white blood cells that use a special
instrument called the receptor to
identify the cancer cells as foreign by
the 90s the immunology researchers have
shown that T cells but unfortunately in
and much too timid way too bad
with elderlies for fishing set let's ask
Orchestra to illustrate VAT give you to
volunteer but alas so short slow and
water playing and anthem pianissimo was
not enough to eliminate cancer cells
that's looped counselor Sheldon all of
this year's Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine goes to two researchers who
discovered how we can release the brakes
that hold back the immune system now by
mobilizing it for cancer therapy for
accountable hunting both laureates are
immunologist but neither was actually a
cancer researcher from the beginning
this story therefore illustrates
something important the unexpected
benefits of basic research brake pedal
that we can he tested a very bold idea
of releasing the brake pedal by using
antibodies to trigger t-cell reactions
against cancer with cancer he began by
curing cancer in mice if any work step
by step to develop this therapy funding
for medical Mikey called it checkpoint
inhibition you don't the first clinical
studies of a malignant melanoma some
patients responded dramatically even in
patients with a disease all over the
bodies the metastasis shrank away and
disappear gift
thoughts go home you had already
discovered a new molecule on t-cells in
the early 90s including many years of
systematic work he was able to show that
it serves as another braking mechanism
in the immune system
he's bye-bye Allison he showed that
blocking this break also triggered
attacks on the cancer cells in mind
and that it works in a new way anything
you put knit or committee floor craft
it's at clinica for second opinion
suggested that his mic we developed into
a powerful cancer from urine clinical
researchers were later able to cover his
hypothesis Deena you're charged with
static affected to do this form of
checkpoint inhibition leads to responses
in more patients and also works against
additional forms of cancer let's get a
preview the new system orchestra sounds
we release the brakes
[Music]
[Applause]
a little effort fortissimo castrating
the immune system in the right way it is
possible to control or eliminate the
disease in tens of thousands of patients
many are still tumor free and after more
than five years already solid and the
Laureus discoveries have inspired a
whole new field of research things felt
like the common overture it promises an
exciting a future for something
professors Allison and Hangzhou your
groundbreaking research has added a
fourth pillar in cancer therapy it
represents a new paradigm for treatment
not directly targeting the cancer cells
but rather releasing the brakes of the
immune system your seminal discoveries
constitute the landmark in the fight
against cancer for the benefit of
numerous patients and all humankind on
behalf of the Nobel assembly as
Karolinska Institutet I wish to convey
to you our warmest congratulations may I
now ask you to step forward to receive
the Nobel Prize from the hands of His
Majesty the King
first James Ellison who she's half of
the price allison of the University of
Texas in the United States
the other half of the price to Tesco hon
you're at the Kyoto University in Kyoto
Japan
[Music]
[Applause]
now some more music not Carmen future
but we will hear destroyer hala
Elizabeth greeting from Tannhauser by
Richard
once again with Southwest Christina
Nelson
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yes - traitor - come here hug hector
aiready please togehter mean Adama
marrow he'll run wallets economy please
harmed our own economy still vexed along
sick well the economic growth has been
almost non-existent throughout most of
human history but a couple of centuries
ago this began me my grandfather on I
was born in 1914 so the world around him
change radically during the course of
his life over the decades and centuries
a few percent of the growth each year
can eyes are what are liam knots will go
on does not occur everywhere it does not
just you ride like a full vice what
drives how long can it continue what can
can we deal with increasingly obvious
downsides of greenhouse gas emissions
are changing for the first time in our
history the climate of our entire world
here growth and new technology have
given you that kind of power to shape
our living conditions and not eat the
just for us how should we use this in a
way that doesn't risk the welfare of
future these are a thought-provoking
questions and the answers are absolutely
vital once one starts to think
it's hard to think about what is yours
your heads full rumor have given us
entirely new tools for investigating
fundamental questions about the causes
and consequences of cancer all over lay
the foundation of what we now call under
Chinese this is new ideas as motors for
growth scientific progress like written
language and mathematics of course these
IDs are amazingly important but we even
were not enough to start a sustained
girls mixed romance Tedrow mysterious
focuses on how economic motivation
drives businesses but ideas are not like
people can use one of the same idea the
problem is problematic if an idea is
freely
shows how intelligent market regulation
a patent system creates on the idea we
realize that broad analysis of climate
change and what to do about it requires
us to bring together insights from
physics chemistry and economics this was
how he built the first integrated
assessment then it describes how
economic activity causes greenhouse gas
emissions how these gases spread through
the atmosphere this change since the
climate and too close to serve how to
climb that influence is the economy in
welfare and in the future on to them nor
houses model in space the best way for
us to approach to control
prai's such as through a carbon tax high
enough emissions prices also steer
technological development towards more
sustainable power provision linking
together the contributions of Nordhaus
that was a firm where it is probably in
human nature to think about a plan for
the future even after our own lives have
ended because if we do not think about
the future times mean we cannot have one
dear professor nor house dared professor
Romer your research has given us deep
insights into the causes and
consequences of climate change and
technological innovation the tools you
have developed broaden the scope of
economic analysis allowing us to think
about the future in new and better ways
it's an honor and privilege to convey to
you on behalf of the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences our warmest
congratulations I now ask you to receive
your prizes from His Majesty the King
economics prize was not originally in
the will of Alfred Nobel II was
established in 1968 celebrating 50 years
then but this is the 49th time it's
being given to scientists
yes to receive his William Nordhaus a TA
of Yale University
for his dice model model that makes it
possible to put a price on climate
change and Paul Romer a guru within
research of economic growth relative at
New York University
[Music]
and this was the last price awarded
today since there's no literature price
this year
due to the problems in the swedish
academy in the literature awarding
institution so hereby we end the 2018
about price award ceremony with a
swedish national anthem
[Music]
and the final musical piece is the queen
of sheba's systems in March which is
played while the guests are leaving
tutorial
[Music]
front-row seats or occupied by members
of the Swedish government another guests
of home
love honor that will take place at the
table of honor at the banquet that
begins in a little bit more than an hour
so the 1500 guests here are going out to
bustin caps driving downtown to the
Stockholm City Hall where the banquet
will take place
[Music]
as laureates James Allison
fresco horn yo both Ashkan jicama who
Donna Strickland Francis all of George
Smith's a greater winter who Nordhaus
Paul Romer and Peace Laureates
Dennis MacGregor and Nadia more rod
thank you from stock up
[Music]
[Applause]
you